I think for the first 20 or so years I
really lived through that lens of future
regret like whenever I didn't know how
it would turn out and was afraid of
doing something I would use that model
of okay imagine I'm on my deathbed and
looking back and like I wish I had
started this thing and trying to make it
so painful that it forces me to take
action right like the Rock and chair
test you're you're in an old age home
you're at the end of your life and like
now you actually can't do it it's too
late and then giving yourself advice
back to today and I used that for 20
years and it really really really helped
me the shift that I've made in the past
four years is trying to shortcut my
brain out of the equation doing the
regret test for me means that you have
to catch it but I think a lot of times
we don't even catch that we're afraid we
just automatically say no to our ideas
we just see that thing and come up with
some reason why we can't can't do it you
know I'm I'm too old I'm too young I'm
too I'm too whatever and when you can go
through the mental exercise to then say
okay well I'm I'm afraid and so what
would I you know my 85-year-old self
tell me I think that definitely helps
when you catch it and when you don't
catch it then what do you do and so the
past four years what I really focused on
is
one the fact that I got the idea means I
have to do it so just because I came up
with the idea means I'm going to get
started on it
and so it's I want to shortcut my brain
out of the equation because your brain's
designed to keep you safe your brain's
designed to keep you small your brain's
designed to keep you protected and so
your brain is not usually the one coming
up with these amazing things to do with
like your heart wants to go and change
the world and your brain tells you you
can't do that who do you think you are
to be able to do that and so I want to
try to shortcut my brain out of the
equation so the idea of just going from
idea to action gets me to just go and do
it because they came up with it the
thing that's helped me through this of
getting started is just get an idea and
go and go do something about it like
expect it to suck expect it to have a
million mistakes don't judge yourself
for how well you know the thing does but
just you just start because you came up
with the idea and so trust in your ideas
because your best ideas are often the
ones that don't make sense for someone
like you to do my brain keeps me small
and I want to play Big need motivation
watch's your top 10 with believe Nation
hey it's EV Carl Michael and I make
these videos is because I want to wake
up and feel like today is going to
matter that I can do something special
and the way that I get that feeling is I
see people who are doing amazing things
and in watching them say amazing things
and do amazing things it makes me feel
like I can do amazing things too so I
hope that this video helps you feel like
you can do something amazing today as
well so today you get to learn from me
and my team's take on my top 10 rules of
success
enjoy rule number two be of service to
others if you're not happy it's because
you're not serving and they did
functional MRIs on people's brains and
found that serving other people lights
up the same part of your brain as having
food and having sex so you're you're
literally hardwired to serve and I think
if and we just I think everybody
listening especially to your show would
would know this and feel this that if if
you woke up every day and felt like
you're not going to serve anybody that
nobody cares if you show up or not that
what you do is meaningless like that's a
pretty desperate path down to stress and
anxiety and depression and suicide uh
very dark things but if you woke up and
felt like today I'm going to make
something that's going to matter to
somebody whether it's for you making you
know an interview a podcast whether it's
an artist creating a piece of art
whether it's somebody showing up to work
and just feeling like today I may not
change the world but but I'm going to
help one person like if you felt that
consistently every every day that you're
going to help at least one person holy
cow does it completely change how you
show up and so I think if you're not
happy it's because you're not serving
and some people you and I we want to
serve the world huge Mission serve the
world change Consciousness you know all
of it great yeah uh and others you may
not have a big Vision you know my wife
doesn't want to change the world but she
still wants to serve and she's the glue
for our family she's remembering
everybody's birthdays and getting the we
had Halloween last night she's getting
all the trick-or treat candy out for all
the kids and remembering all of these
things uh and so but either way you're
built to serve either the world or the
closest people to you and if you're not
happy it's CU you're not serving rule
number three is build your brand when
you have a giant impact you're able to
sell a whole lot more and again as you
continue to build your brand so many
other opportunities will come up to you
that you can't even realize or think
about right now I mean Alex Heros is a
great case study or example where he he
was building all his marketing direct
marketing having you know whatever you
know $100 million net worth Etc and then
saw that uh one of the Kardashians had
more net worth than he did it's like how
is this possible like I'm so much better
as a business person than this person
and he go well because they have brand
and you don't because you're just doing
direct marketing and so you need to
build a brand and that's what pushed him
over the edge to say I need to go and
build the brand because ultimately I'm
going to sell way more if people know me
and know me and like me more than just
they saw one of my advertisements and
that is been a big shift in the industry
where we've seen lots of people move
over from direct marketing starts to now
building the brand rule number four is
do what you love if you actually enjoyed
the thing people ask me why don't like
how have you dealt with burnout on your
YouTube channel yeah because all these
creators talking about burnout right now
I was like burnout what's that well I
mean I I definitely had burnout from
stuff but not like if you made me an
accountant if I have to look at
paperwork I'm going to burn out in 18
minutes but making videos and helping
entrepreneurs and to your word of like
the intention and service I've been
doing this for 14 years now we haven't
missed an upload in a decade
probably because this is it's not this
doesn't work for me being here doing
this this isn't work this is fun like
this is
awesome and so I think if you are only
tied to the results of course I care
about results of course I want to grow
of course I want
have an impact of course but it's not
the main driver where I think of that's
all and that's what a lot of achievers
are only focused on the end result but
then they're not happy as they go
through it where the process becomes
even more important that you love it and
you're having fun doing it because
otherwise that's the path of burning out
if you don't love the thing that you're
waking up every day to do you will burn
out pretty quickly but if you love it
then it never feels like you're going to
work it's like I can't wait to go off
and do this also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is study successful
people we've studied successful people
you know I've probably studied more
successful people than than most people
and the number one rule for success is
that you love the process you have to
like love the actual work that you're
doing that it doesn't feel like work
that it's we're all all trying to have
an impact and get results and you know
you care how many views you get Etc you
know the the external numbers but at the
course you still have to love the actual
process and one of the things that I
love doing is being able to pull rules
for Success from people who a lot of
people may not instantly connect with
like Connor does a lot of things that
would throw a lot of people off you know
he's a he's a lightning bolt he's he
does he does some things that rub people
the wrong way and they would never give
him um a chance at all to to hear you
know some of his wisdom but he's out a t
success you know and anybody who's had a
lot of success I want to learn something
from and doesn't mean that your goal is
to be the next Conor McGregor but you
could learn something from him and I've
I've tried especially to try to learn
from people who I may not like right out
of the gate for whatever reason because
they often have the most to teach you if
you only learn from people who are
exactly like you you're you're by
definition limiting how much you learn
so uh the challenge with Connor was
going through and saying okay I mean
he's got all these interviews of him
doing all sorts of crazy things which is
fine and you know Conor you do you and
there's also a lot of wisdom there's a
lot of wisdom you know if so that video
with Connor uh it wasn't him trash
talking somebody making fun of
somebody's mom or you know whatever else
but there's a lot of wisdom in there and
uh that's one of the things that I love
doing rule number six is discover your
core value I'm a believer that everybody
has a single most important core value
so for me I'd say believe right so I I I
want to spread more believe in the world
and whatever our message is to the world
is still what we need the most ourselves
and the next level of our breakthrough
is on the other side of even more of
that thing so my next level breakthrough
is on the other side of even more belief
if 95 year-old Evan was going to come
and talk to me right now he'd say dude
believe in yourself more your next
breakthrough is on the side of even more
love and people might say Josh dude like
you're already the most loving person
that I know like how could there be even
more love but but that's the pursuit of
Excellence right like there's this isn't
even the start of how much love you
could potentially share both both
internally like self-love plus love out
how do you bring more love to your
audience to the guests who come on to
the team who show up to the people who
buy your products and services as well
as to self and so um that's a frame of
reference that I use for myself at least
to say okay like the if I believed in
myself more what would I do what would
the next thing be because 95-year-old
Evan is is pissed that I'm not off doing
the bigger thing and it took me so long
to get here just like now looking back
it's like how come it took me 5 years to
get some videos going up to get past
2,000 subscribers not in a negative way
like you suck looking backwards but
let's use that as fuel going forward to
make the bigger play to to LEAP faster
into self-belief in my case to allow me
to go and do more because another one of
the things my mom used to say is if you
have the ability you have the
responsibility if you can then you must
and so uh I believe that if you're
someone who's filled with love you have
the responsibility to go off and share
like it's not enough to hold that for
yourself you have to go off and do more
with it like you can't settle for where
you're at right now my belief right um
and I think that's what Achievers kind
of hold themselves to that it's great
everything we've done and I'm capable of
more and more not just for me but more
to serve and to help and to inspire and
to spread more positivity around the
world rule number seven is conquer your
fears I come up with trigger words so
scary difficult hard are my trigger
words where if I think it if I say it if
I feel it if I write it if I text it
scary difficult or hard then I have to
do it just because yeah so the fact that
this question says you know that they're
afraid of starting that is scary
difficult hard if that was a a reason
for me to not do something then I have
to do it
just because because I want to be the
person who does scary difficult hard
things because my my goals my dreams are
on the other side of doing scary
difficult and hard yes and so we've
accepted these reasons for not taking
action so if if I was this person and
and the the trigger word here would be
fear so you want to be the person who
does the things that you are afraid of
so anytime fear is the reason now of
course don't go jumping out of an
airplane with no parachute you know like
these are that's that's just stupid
right but allowing fear to run your life
means you will never have a great life
rule number eight is discover your heart
print I think whatever your most
important core value is your who that is
your heart
print so I want to spread more belief in
the world you want to spread more love
in the
world uh and so that's why understanding
what your who is becomes really valuable
and I split it into two things of the
thing that I'm missing the most is even
more
belief you know whatever that is like
people would look at you and say but you
are Mr love Ryan yeah but the thing that
you're missing even more is more love
you want to transcend it's on the other
side of even more love more love for
self and more love for others and what
does that look like and when you figure
that out then like it's the you're like
shedding a new skin and now you're
you're free again and the same thing for
me every every major growth in my my
life not just business has been on the
other side of even more belief belief in
s and then trying to spread more belief
out to the world and so um I hope that
uh that's what my heart print is a
constant reminder to me as well as what
I can create for others rule number nine
is be strategic SEO is different in the
YouTube game people think of YouTube as
the second largest search engine in the
world which it is but most of the views
don't actually come from search it'll
come from browse and suggested which
means either the YouTube homepage or if
you type in something on search uh how
to Market my business somebody's going
to rank there and get that video click
but then from your own experience you'll
watch that video and then you'll watch
the videos down the side and you'll
watch the videos that show up after much
more than you'll go back to see what
we're under the search term so you might
get one view from search but then you'll
get eight nine 10 more views from
suggested down the side so the real game
is not ranking for search the real game
is ranking after the videos that are
ranking for
search suggested so so the way to do it
for anybody this is a great hack for
anybody who's you know who's listening
watching um think about who is the
number one person in your industry what
kind of videos are they making and then
going and looking at what kind of
content they're creating and then take
almost the exact same title and make
your version of that video not I don't
care what's in the video I don't care
what they're talking about or how
they're doing it because you're the
expert you're the thought leader I want
your opinion all I want you to do is
take that title because your goal is to
rank after that person's video so they
just watch them so if it's a marketing
video uh you know maybe you watch a Gary
ve video like how to Market on Instagram
in 2020 uh and then you call it the same
video the same title I want them to
watch Gary and then I want them to watch
you and that's how you start siphoning
audiences and amplifying your voice and
Rule Number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is quit playing
small we play small because we don't
know how to accomplish our big things
and we settle for the small thing yeah
which which is fine in the in the I'm
going to I'm going to 2x or 3x my
business knowing that this is a base is
going to help me do my big thing but the
big thing is is unclear and that's also
okay like the the whole point of
building the base to 3x is that you
don't have to have the next thing make
you a ton of money yet yeah but it'll
lead to
Opportunities
so personal
finance being a thought leader there's
lots of options there's lots of models
that have already been proven out you
have to build the base right you have to
take it more seriously you have to
create more content you have to be more
powerful in your opinions you like
there's a lot of work that has to get
done but it's not that nobody has never
done it so you make money from brain
deals from sponsorships from speaking
gigs from ad revenue from book launches
from your own products like the thing is
you won't know where you're going to
make the money until you start getting
into it you can have a plan but you
won't know until you get into
it I think everybody can can lean in and
learn whatever they want to learn um I
had the Good Fortune of having some
great parents they're on their wall
behind behind me here I'm 8 or N9 years
old and those are my parents there and
they would always tell me hey you carich
like you do anything you believe that
you can and so they helped instill that
in me um I think the whole you know the
Gary Vee's point about are you born with
it well what were you doing at 7 years
old like were you doing lemonade stains
and garage sales and taking some
initiative um but if you weren't don't
feel like oh my gosh now I can't be an
entrepreneur it's it's so much easier
now than ever to start your own business
or to lean in on the thing for sure like
I believe everybody's got Michael Jordan
level genius at something like you're
the greatest in the world at something
and you just don't believe that you are
and you don't believe in your dreams
enough to go chase them down but you can
whether it's being an entrepreneur and
believing in your business whether it's
believing in your health Journey that
it's possible whether it's you know
climbing Mount kilero or losing 100
pounds or like whatever the thing is
that you'd love to do it's it's possible
possible people like you have done it
and that's where a lot of people get
stuck is like well it's possible like
somebody else has done it but I can't do
it because I'm whatever and my story
early with the YouTube stuff was um I'm
an introvert I'm shy so I'm I'm not
going to make it you know but I'll keep
making content because I'm serving but
I'm I'm never going to be the big name
because I'm too introverted and too shy
and I still am by the way it just
doesn't come out when I'm doing shows
like this um but you can you know you
can whatever whatever that story is in
your head it's totally fixable and other
people you know like you have done it
and it just comes down to starting to
change what you put into your head I
think that's the biggest thing of all
that's why I make so much content
because if somebody felt like their
health Journey was impossible you know
it's like you know Jay you don't
understand I was impossible you know
it's like you know J you don't
understand
I've been like this and my family has
been like this and it's just not
possible and I've tried a million things
and just nothing works and it's it's
never gonna happen Jay this that's
that's who I am right if they spent a
month with you you know because you're
more confident in their ability to get
healthy than they are and their
inability to get
healthy and same thing with me if
somebody's hanging out with me for an
extented period of time if we were
hanging out together uh I'm going to get
a lot healthier
probably and you're going to be making
more YouTube videos man we're going to
get you on there and and crushing it
because whoever is more confident wins
and so the problem is we're surrounded
by people who don't believe in our
dreams who tell us that it's not
possible and we're also feeding our mind
with things that keep us stuck where we
are and if you want to change something
it's totally possible but it starts with
actually changing um that environment so
that you have a you have the crutch like
to get going to get you out of the
Starting Gate so I think a lot of people
try to forget about the past pain I
think especially entrepreneurs we're so
you know optimistic we want to make the
world better we're trying to live in a
positive Place uh that I had actually a
hard time remembering some of the super
painful moments and I don't like going
there but instead of trying to forget
and move past it if you can go live
there again just as a reminder of what
it felt like so that you can then help
other people living there and dwelling
on mistakes and and the hurt doesn't
help anything right but if it allows you
to connect with the people who are
currently going through that situation
and I think that becomes your path like
for the reason why I came up with
purpose from your pain is it's one of
the most common questions I get is
what's my purpose how do I find my
people are walking around with no
purpose they don't know what it is and I
think everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something I think you can be a
genius at something and I know that like
Unleash Your greatness is what you're
all about it's great uh but people don't
know how to find it and I think it
starts with that it starts with
understanding some of the pain and
Trauma that you've been through whatever
that was for you and then then create
something amazing you know every great
organization every great entrepreneur
who started out of a pain that they had
and then they want to go off and solve
it and so diving back into your past to
think about what were some really
painful moments and then how can you
turn that as a kick forward not a kick
down not that you know you suck but
you're gonna now help others and and
make it better um and sharing the story
I think it's how entrepreneurs win I
think I think too often we're afraid to
share a lot of people be afraid to share
your story like you're coming out of
Tony Robins organization you're on top
of the world you're improving people's
lives and and you're sitting you know in
your parents basement and it's five
years like that that story is what makes
people human it's what connects people
to each other and I think so many people
who are trying to start a business uh
try to be so corporate and so
professional and it's not that you can't
be professional but the thing that's
going to make somebody want to work with
you and connect with you in your mission
is your story I need to know why this is
so important to you why is this pain so
important and if you're telling some you
know fluffy story it's not going to work
but if it's true and real to you then
that's what's really going to draw
people in if you're trying to get your
journey going on YouTube cool take a
bite and see try making videos try doing
Vlogs try doing interviews try doing
directed camera try doing speeches try
the things that you see and expect to
suck at all of them at the beginning
you're not going to good because you
don't have the skill set yet doesn't
mean you suck as a human you just you
don't have the skill set yet but the
thing to pay attention to is did you
enjoy it how did you feel after doing it
you had that interview and it's easy to
go back if you go back and watch your
first interview it's a train wack it
mean you're awkward and nervous and ask
the wrong questions and you can look
back on it and say oh my gosh I should
have done that and you can go over it in
your head a million times but like but
did you like it you know like was it fun
to do do you want to go back and do it
again did it give you more energy than
it took and if it's a yes then that's a
great sign to keep
going and so a lot of people stop on
YouTube because they don't get immediate
results because they're not doing
something that they feels authentic to
them um and they're focused on who
they're not serving instead of who they
are serving um and they just judge
themselves too harshly for not having
the skill set yet like you don't just
get on a snowboard and go down the hill
you fall 80 times on your first run and
then you fall 50 times on your second
run right and you just you get better as
you go why is it necessary that's one
word for Branding your business so I
think it comes in two forms I think it
starts with you I think it gives you the
clear perspective on what your brand is
all about I think a lot of times when
people coming up with a brand they don't
you know they're they're picking
something because it looks nice or it
sounds good but it's not coming from a
really deep place of meaning and the
brand needs to mean something first to
you like you need to be proud of
everything that you're creating and it
has to have a has to have a heartbeat
everything you make has to have a
heartbeat whether that's a creating
content or or creating the service like
you do coaching you do
Consulting that has to you have to help
people thrive in in those sessions or
you're not going to be you know happy
about that um and so it it gives you a
frame of reference for yourself first
that then that flows through everything
flows into your entire business how you
operate your company uh you know you
want to bring on people to your team who
believe in similar things as you do if
you're hiring a video editor you know my
video editor wanted to tattoo believe on
her arm before she even met
me she she you know she believes in the
same thing and so you want to bring
people on who have the skill set but
also believe the same thing that you
believe and if you don't know what you
believe then you'll attract anybody but
if you're really specific on what you
believe then it's easy to bring people
in who are on the same Mission that's an
internal brand and most people look at
the external which we can get to but
like that's the internal brand you need
the internal Compass because if the
external is one thing and the internal
is something else you're not going to be
happy you're going to feel like a fake
you're going to feel like you're always
having to live up to something that
you're not the external then is what
people perceive it as what when people
see your your content when people see
your product or service your your
branding your your Instagram and YouTube
and all of that what do they think what
do they feel if it's too complicated you
know they won't be able to share it
people people could love your stuff but
if they can't articulate it clearly to
their friends and their colleagues
they're not going to share it I think of
uh corporations that have their 13 core
values that nobody actually knows nobody
shares it because it's too complicated
like if you need me to remember five
things about you to share it I'm not
going to it's just even if I love you
like I'd have to love you insanely a lot
to remember those five things but if
it's if it's one thing and people know
me for belief they want more believe in
their life it's you should talk to Evan
you should go watch his YouTube channel
you should subscribe to him you should
check out what he's doing
it's just easy to remember because
people have busy lives it's not that
they don't want to talk about you you're
just making it too complicated you're
introducing too much friction to them
what do you think would gravitate
towards negativity a lot more when we
know it doesn't make us feel good
because it definitely drains you it
causes an impact I think it's biological
it's like you it's like from the history
of US struggling right has to you I mean
I don't know I don't not I'm not a
scientist and I don't have all the
answers there for sure but but
like why do we slow down and look at a
car
accident even if it's on the other side
of the road totally get hit by looking
at Happ like if a fight breaks out on
the street it's like you're you know you
want to see what happens like where we I
don't know where it comes from but like
it it it definitely is that people would
rather um consume negative things like
if I my first video was the top 10 rules
for Kanye West and was positive things
you can learn from Kanye if that was a
negative like top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said it would it would do so
much better because I think I think if
I'm looking at it from the perspective
of what I do is like we we would rather
see people fail than than try to build
ourselves up right you know it's like oh
look at D she she's got her podcast and
she's been on movies and look at her
building her life and she she made it
out and now she's in LA and she's such a
big deal and y y yada and it's easier
for me to try to tear you down and want
to see you fail then for me to say huh
like maybe I can fix my life maybe I can
go to La too maybe I can start a podcast
maybe I can and and whatever the things
are that you know jealousy is really
just um ins inspiration that's been
mutated oh wow if I if I'm jealous of
you I'm actually inspired by you but I
don't know how to handle it so I take it
negative totally
so it's easier for me to tear you
down than for me to try to work on
myself because I don't have to do any
work that way right it's like yeah but
then yeah but she like totally sold her
soul to go do that and she and I'll make
I make up some stuff that like doesn't
even make sense but it allows me to stay
where I'm at where I am right so that's
why a lot of a lot of even our friends
and family will often say not to go do
something because if you go off if you
go off to LA and you start becoming a
movie star and you start meeting people
what does it mean for
me you know like you left me behind and
and now my life sucks because you're
showing what's possible and I'm living
in a fake reality I don't want to accept
that so it's not possible you must have
had to do something super
scammy terrible yeah like you killed
somebody or whatever you know you hide
someone in the closet and it's not
coming out yeah yeah so I think that's
like it we don't doing work on yourself
is hard very learning new skills and
making new connections and going to a
new country or new city is hard it's
really hard and we don't want to do hard
things but your great life is on the
other side of of hard things and so when
we see somebody else who looks like us
comes from similar
background we want to find a reason why
that person should not be successful
we'd rather hate on them than be
inspired not everybody but a lot of
people yeah because we want we prefer to
stay stuck than the grow how could
someone like take their business and
evolve it with them what kind of things
could they
do just think about what is it that you
want to create so for example I had a
successful website it was off my name we
had lots of successful people writing
for it um making money off advertising
coming to the site I was getting
restless and so I said I'm going to try
something new I'm GNA I want to go to
YouTube I'm going to try that and I
tried a whole bunch of stuff like you
try things you don't know at the
beginning it was going to work out or
not so I tried YouTube as one of many
things and I liked it and so I kept
doing it and then I kept doing it and I
evolved my business a lot of people
don't even know me for my website they
only know me from my YouTube channel
yeah right because we we've blown up
there but if I get bored of YouTube like
the minute that like I like talking to
you this is great Michael's Michael's do
an interview I love it let's get on
board the this feels like work like it's
oh man I got to talk I got to do another
interview this sucks I I need to quit I
need to do something else because you
will never win doing work that you hate
okay and so the minute that this feels
like a job I need to stop and go off and
do something else what is it something
else you know like just ask yourself
what what what would I do what do I want
to do what do I want to work on yeah you
may not have the perfect vision yet for
like the final goal but find some small
thing to get started on if you were
looking at me and saying Andrea you got
to Define your Niche you got to choose
one or the other or is there a way to
imerge two things into one in your
opinion so if you're looking at your
audience and picking your Niche what I
what I love to do is build around a core
value so if you do if you're looking at
health and
spirituality those are not mutually
exclusive like you can't have health
without spirituality and you can't
spirituality without Health right I mean
like they go together and so the trick
in like what is your Niche is like what
is the Andrea brand well it's about
what's on what's on top of that that
makes it all make sense so uh if you are
only talking about spirituality that had
no connection to health and only talk
about health that had no connection to
spirituality then those could live as
two separate YouTube channels and
products and Brands but one it's a lot
more work for someone like you to manage
right like now we got to manage two
social media accounts across everything
and it's also less of an expression of
who you are because you're always
limited by I can't talk about this stuff
because I'm only focused on X and so the
exercise that I like to go through with
people is like what sits on top so if
you had to think who does you know what
is Andrea stain for that's spirituality
is part of it and health is part of it
and maybe something else is part of it
too but what sits above like what what's
the mother word where spirituality and
health are children
I think everybody has an agenda for you
uh your parents your friends your family
your kids like everybody has an agenda
for you and if you don't understand what
your agenda is for yourself then you'll
just be pulled in a thousand different
directions and never accomplish anything
that you actually want to go off and
accomplish and so chances are whatever
the thing is that you have greatness in
whatever you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at uh it's going to make some
people upset you know even out of love
like saying that you want to go off and
do this but uh your parents don't think
that that's the right thing for you or
or nobody in your family has ever done
it it's easy for them to pull you down
and prevent you from going off and doing
the thing that you actually want to do
and so the common trait of everybody
who's had massive success is being able
to deal with the people around them
telling them that their idea suck that
it's never going to work and you still
get up and you go and you do it anyway
for a lot of people the advice that your
parents are giving you is out of love
they love you they just see success
differently they grw up in a different
world and so success to them looks one
way and you're off doing this crazy
other path and so they just care about
you and they're trying to do the best
thing that they think is for you but the
the worst advice you can give somebody
is what you would do in a
situation that's the worst advice you
can give them here's what I would do
well who cares what you would do you're
not me right but like never get like the
best advice you can give is try to
understand that person and give them the
answer that will help them even if it's
not the same thing that you would do and
so I think a lot of people that's the
real trouble spot where there's people
who love you who are trying to help you
and they think they're helping you but
they're not um because that's what they
would do how you can model success this
is what saved my business when I wanted
to quit at my company my first software
company and then I realized that you
know what I'm not the first guy to try
to sell software before like somebody
has figured this
out if I just learn from that person I
can apply those strategies to my
business and so I modeled Bill Gates who
started Microsoft and I've never met
Bill Gates but he saved my company and I
looked at the strategies of how did he
start Microsoft not how does Microsoft
grow now who cares it's a huge company
but like start how did he start zero to
one that's what I wanted to do and I
modeled him and I applied that to my
business and we started to grow and so
whatever dreams whatever goals whatever
business you have somebody's already
figured it out may not be exactly what
you want to do and that's good because
you're different you're an entrepreneur
you're going to put your own twist on it
but people have already figured it out
and so understanding what they did and
trying to break down their success could
be really helpful so that if you're
hustling and grinding you're spending
your time on the right things that will
help you as opposed to the things that
aren't leading to
success so so when you say model after
them you you mean like you don't
necessarily have to meet this person you
can just read their books or watch their
interviews is that how you learned from
from Bill Gates for example yeah so
there's two kinds of mentors there's the
regular mentors that people think about
where you go for coffee and they're you
know local you can go meet them and they
break down your business uh and I never
had that right like my parents taught me
so much about life and being a human
being but never about business and
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur
and so I had nobody to go and have
coffee with I went to my banker and said
hey can you help me with my business
he's like well do you need a loan like
no I don't know do I need a loan I don't
know he's like yeah you're not really in
the right place like I didn't know
anybody and so I Look to what I call
aspirational Mentor these the people who
you aspire to be like or aspire to learn
from and some people may have already
passed on and you'll never meet them
like I have Steve Jobs up on my wall I'm
never going to meet him obviously um and
a lot of people behind me uh some I may
meet one day or some have passed on uh
and so I would look at two kinds of what
I call aspirational mentors the first
are in your industry whatever you want
to do somebody has done it you want to
be a successful YouTuber there's lots of
people who've done it Go and model them
see what they did the more successful
they are the more information there is
on them whether it's interviews or books
or magazine articles like their story is
somewhere and again look to how they got
started as opposed to what they're doing
now because it's a different scale and
then the second kind are just the people
who you look up to you know if if I love
Oprah Winfrey I can learn something from
her even if I don't want to have my own
talk show you know if you love Michael
Jordan you could learn from him even if
you never want to be a basketball player
like the way that he works and his
hustle and effort he's in the gym you
can apply that to your life and to your
business even if you never go on to try
to become an NBA player so those two
things the people who have done what you
want to do maybe you hate them but you
can still learn from their success right
and just do it your way and then the
people who you just really look up to
and really admire and say one day I want
to have that kind of impact again
understanding how they got started and
modeling their success to help you get
your breakthrough on your mission that
you're on what challenges with that
format that you've built uh have you
faced for what's next and what's been
the advantage of that format for what
you've been able to build and the impact
that you're making in the world my
biggest limitation is still lack of
belief
so people say but you're the Bel guy
it's like yeah but I believe in myself
to do the things that I've done now but
to do the next the next big thing I
don't believe myself to do the next big
so I still need the channel for myself
because I want to wake up and have Oprah
Winfrey or Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or
whoever it is wh spring messages in my
ear to get me going to do the next thing
um one of my my uh talk about the format
of of giving tribute to other people uh
at the beginning it was just hey I've
learned this from these people and I
think you might be able to learn too I
was just hoping to shortcut the path cuz
my my worst day in my first business was
when I set quit on my business partner
and I woke up the next day and said I
can't quit yet cuz I'm going to regret
this if I don't figure this out at least
at least if it doesn't work out fine but
at least know that I gave it everything
because I don't want to look back and
say ah I wish I just tried a little bit
harder but I couldn't keep going the way
that I was going so I had to find
another path and the thing that came to
me was I can't be the first person to
try to solve this problem like
somebody's figured this out why don't I
just model success like that wasn't
model success wasn't words that I would
use you know it's probably a lot more
clumsy but I can't be the first person
to figure this out somebody's done it
and that's where I studied Bill Gates
like Bill Gates had a like who's got a
software company I had a software
company who's got a successful software
company Bill Gates came to mind like
this was not very Advanced planning it's
just top of Dome uh so okay how did
Microsoft get started and how did he
build like not so much how did how does
Bill Gates make an extra million dollars
now who cares but like zero to one how
do you do that and it was through
Partnerships and and learning how he
applied that in Microsoft I brought that
to my business and quickly after had my
first check for
$135,000 and that may not seem like a
lot but when you're making 300 bucks a
month like 13 and a 12K it's like holy
cow this is a grand slim here and more
importantly I could do that again that
was just one deal I could close more
deals so the idea the strategy there was
model success find people who have done
this and put that to use in your
business or your life and so I I then
went on this mission to continue
learning how I can model other people
success and then I that eventually
became a YouTube channel where I shared
a lot of messages um a surprising
benefit of that has been I've gotten to
meet some of these people you know like
I was just profiling some of them and
then now I get to do interviews with
them or go hang out with them or go to
their houses and some of them become
friends which was never part of the idea
of what I could do it's just hey I love
your
message I'm trying to get it out to the
world cuz if I learn from it maybe other
people like me can learn from it and
it's been amazing to be able to Foster
lot of those connections too how do you
feel
about this kind of like world that is
going speeding so quickly with
information how do you find that Focus
to be like okay I have my faith but it's
overwhelming like what how do you find
that kind of place so first step like
the first step for me is flipping it to
get excited so when something new comes
out it's like okay I'm excited to I'm
excited to go learn that thing AI comes
out cool let's go let's go learn about
AI it's like expecting to suck at it I
don't know anything about AI I don't
know how to program AI didn't know how
to do anything inside of AI and okay
let's go learn we're we're filming this
video on the on the the day after
Instagram or Facebook just launches
threads right right so threads just come
out it's a Twitter competition and most
people are like oh my gosh threads
another social media thing why do we
need another place to go and doom scroll
on and great like I'm a let me learn
about threads this is exciting I just
try to teach myself that when there's
something new let's go learn it it's
exciting because the rate of change is
not going to go slower right I agree so
so this becomes your key uh adaptation
technique is that any anytime something
new comes out get excited go learn about
it this is how you can start to win and
for anybody who is earlier on in their
Journey whenever something new comes out
that actually becomes your secret hack
to go off and win so if you're trying to
get started and you're on Twitter it
might be hard for you to to win right
now because people have already been it
doesn't mean that you can so you start
you start creating great but go to
threads it's brand new it's all the
people who are on Twitter like don't
want to go to threads because they up
Their audience all the people in
Hollywood didn't want to go to
YouTube right like where's Brad Pitt's
YouTube channel he should be crushing
right now totally because he doesn't
want to start over right this is the
problems like people don't want to start
over and I don't know anything about
Brad Pit no shaded Brad uh but like some
people make the jump like Will Smith
make the jump and like starts blowing up
on YouTube but a lot of people don't a
lot of people stick to one platform and
then they they slowly become irrelevant
and so when something new comes up this
is your chance to go off and win like
you might not beat Joe Rogan at
podcasting but you can beat him on
threads or you can get close to him on
threads and a lot of the people who are
are winning in that first platform just
don't want to go and start over on the
second one and so this is your chance to
get ahead and so whether it's AI whether
it's threads whether it's an update to
the YouTube algorithm whether it's
whatever the thing is there's more
coming and there and there's more coming
too so training to be the person who
gets excited for new changes because
that's your chance to go and win have a
bigger impact make more money like
whatever actually drives you spread more
faith right whatever actually is driving
you this is your opportunity to go off
and do it and so for me that's always
been the default where like okay why I
don't it's always been a default I think
I've trained myself um to get more
excited about the new things that are
coming up uh and I just go in with a
student mind expect to suck you know
like I don't somebody asked me about
threads today like hey what's your
thread strategy like I don't know I'm
two days in like I'm trying to figure it
I don't even know what this is yet I'm
I'm maybe not the smartest person but
I'm I'm trying to understand it as we go
or when some new AI tool drops okay
let's understand what the heck this
thing even does and learning how to use
it so but it's just getting excited
about it and putting in a little bit of
effort to learn how to do it because so
many people they just get stuck on I
don't know how and it's new and scary
and I don't do anything where really
you're actually not that far away from
making momentum if you just put in a
little bit of effort are you of the
opinion then that if somebody has a job
but they have a feeling that they want
to be um an entrepreneur but they're
afraid of leaving their job are you of
the opinion that they should uh take a
take steps towards that and and if you
have a feeling for something try
it and just see and expect to suck but
at least you tried and you can see you
know do you want to go off and do it
again you had a feeling in in the coffee
shop to come and ask me to connect if
you didn't follow the feeling that would
have been it like I would have my my
breakfast with Joe and then CIA and off
right and I may never see you again you
had to feeling you followed it and it
may not always be good like maybe I'm an
maybe I'm an ass maybe you're like dude
get out of my face you're weird stalking
me out of the bathroom right like maybe
like you don't know you don't know what
would happen but you have a feeling and
you have to follow the feeling cuz
otherwise you teach yourself that the
things that come to you are not great
cuz if every time you get an idea and
you don't follow through you're teaching
yourself that your ideas suck versus I
have an idea I'm going to give it a shot
that's a great identity to start to
build it doesn't mean go mortgage your
home to go start a podcast Studio like
expect to suck and find the smallest
possible thing to just go and get
started so somebody who's working a
corporate job that hates their life okay
you're you're never going to win doing
work that you hate so so longer term
something has to change it doesn't mean
go like take a flamethrower to your
boss's office or something now like you
need the money you need the cool awesome
but longer term like we have to make a
change somewhere because you will never
be great doing work that you hate you're
never going to make the money you're
never going to be happy if you're doing
work you hate every day so how you going
to get out of that hole that you're in
is it going to be somebody else telling
you what you should do with your life
that's going to be like you have ideas
for what you if you cool if I could do
this okay go give it a shot try it see
if you liked it your first podcast
sucked cool then you you get better like
you're better at eight episodes in than
I was at like 300 episodes in right so
but you try and so I think if you have
the feeling you want to teach yourself
that you come up with great ideas and
and they're worth at least giving a shot
to instead of just saying you know
there's sushi on the table I don't like
sushi without even giving a shot cuz it
sounds gross like if you had to explain
what Sushi is raw fish with with fish
eggs and seaweed with rice and super
spicy mustard that doesn't sound
appetizing right like why would anybody
eat that but then you eat it I like sush
with you guys but but you don't know
until you try so like you're judging
things before you're trying it and
especially when it's yourself you're
judging your ideas before you even try
it you're building uh the belief that
your ideas suck and that you suck and
then you stay stuck and so I I at least
you know encourage myself to try to flip
that that I have ideas that saying yes
to you okay let's go I'm not going to
judge it let's go do it I encourage
entrepreneurs to go through um a
three-step process which is eliminate
automate delegate okay so you look at
the work that you're doing and maybe you
shouldn't be doing it at all like before
you give it to somebody else maybe it
just shouldn't get done and there
there's often things that we're doing
that we think a really high value that
then turn out to like to not matter and
we may not even notice it right I mean
before Movie Makers I had a mastermind
that I ran in Toronto for entrepreneurs
and when people joined um we took uh
minutes like notes of what was happening
like I took minutes this before AI could
do it for you and transcripts like I
wrote down minutes for what everybody
said and homework and assignments and
everything and um there was one month
where I forget what happened like I was
going away the next day or something and
I didn't get the notes out to people
after the
meeting nobody
cared like no response no message no
like Hey where's the minutes where's the
notes and I and so I didn't do it again
next month nobody cared it's like wow
I've been spending all this time on
something that like nobody cared about
that I thought was high value but was
actually zero value for people um maybe
it was even negative value maybe I was
annoying them with it I don't know uh
and so eliminate first you know so I
mean a lot of entrepreneurs might be
frustrated with their accounting and
bookkeeping uh you cannot eliminate that
right like that has to get done yeah you
will run into problems if you try to
eliminate that from your business right
and I was gonna go into that for you but
yeah keep going yeah the government will
come for you that is a big problem
unless you live in some country that
that doesn't move to the moon or
something but um yeah you know that's a
problem so can eliminate that but but
there's a lot of things that we're doing
that just should not be done they just
be completely eliminated the next is
automate so before giving it to a human
give it to technology so use software
use tools use AI use QuickBooks use like
there's a lot of things there's software
and tools for a lot of things that you
should should start applying into your
business uh that can save a lot of man
hours um and then you get to delegate so
eliminate automate and then delegate and
so these are the things that still have
to get get done but should not be done
by you so in eliminate they shouldn't be
done at all in automate they need to be
done but should be done by a human and
then in delegate it's it it should be
done but shouldn't be done by you has to
be done by another human and that's
where you start to scale and build and
create something you say that I love is
that you can't out Evan Evan I want to
know what you mean by that yeah I think
a lot of times we we have role models we
have mentors and there's nothing wrong
with it I love I've learned a lot from
the people in my life and people have
profiled on my channel uh but it it's
easy to turn into imposter syndrome to
feel like well I'm never going to be as
good as whoever like you're here
starting this podcast uh and you might
look at Joe Rogan or Tim Ferris or
whoever whoever you think is the best
podcaster interviewer out there but the
goal is never to be Joe Rogan the goal
is to be the best Samuel possible and
that is an evolution and even even at
the beginning if you start asking Joe
Rogen questions that's fine as a as a
you know you're tasting and testing and
getting started but we're always so
worried about chasing our competition
where really the goal should be to be
the best us and so nobody can out Evan
Evan nobody can out Samuel Samuel and so
when people uh will often share videos
with me to say oh look this person
copied your style this person is doing
exactly what you're doing like that's
cool like I don't you're not going to
out me me so if you're just to be a
elfis impersonator great like keep doing
you but ultimately everybody needs to
find their own path so I think so many
times we're worried about the rearview
mirror and what's happening behind us as
opposed to forging our own path to say
okay how am I going to be unique what do
I love doing that other people don't and
going all in on that thing I love
learning different things from different
people I'm in my home office and you can
see pictures for those listeners I guess
there's pictures behind me on the my
parents are in the middle that's
in the middle of me when I'm like eight
or nine and my above me believe my one
word my most important core value comes
from them um they taught me how to be a
human they didn't teach me about
business that's right so okay great I've
got Steve Jobs on the wild here next to
me he I like learning how to be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs yes but I
don't want to be a father like Steve
Jobs was that's right I want to be a
father like my father was that's right
and so I love learning different from
different people I think anybody who's
had success you can learn from them and
I honestly think some of your greatest
learnings will come from people who you
don't like who had success they can
teach you when you can learn to learn
from someone who you don't like is when
I think you actually start learning wow
and so my favorite comment of all time
on my channel i profiled a a a black
entrepreneur and I had a guy leave a
comment and say hey growing up my
parents told told me that black people
were the nword yeah and today I just
learned from a black man yeah absolutely
right it took five minutes to to watch a
video and and be open like hey put your
put your prejudices aside for five
minutes that's right and just see if
there's something here that you might
learn we know what we sell perfect let's
use social media to help us sell more of
our stuff like the the big reason why
people quit is because you feel like
you're wasting time making content and
it's not generating any sales for you
and I'm Mission first purpose first if
anybody is familiar with my content what
I do it's like purpose first and you
have to make money because if you're not
making money you're going to quit on the
thing so how can we make money inside
our purpose instead of having to have
some job that's outside our purpose
right so the next thing to think about
if you know what you're selling or what
you are looking to sell right next is
who are referral partners for us so
actually karms if you look at your
business like who are the types of
people who refer clients to you do you
feel like some people are just that
entrepreneurs are
born I know you say that everybody has
it enough to serve but you there's some
people that are just more prone or um
more gifted or more capable when it
comes to um achieving
entrepreneurship so I think I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something okay uh if you
go religious you know everybody's a
child of God you were created you
beautiful you should be making something
amazing in the world you are not meant
to be living this small life right so if
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something for some people
that's being an entrepreneur for others
it might be being a teacher in the
school right it could be many things how
do you find it well you need to
explore you need to taste you need to
test you know just like you found my
videos you were searching for motivation
and you found them and then you he like
I like this and then you do into it a
lot of times you can't think your way
through these things because chances are
the thing that you should be doing is
very different than what is in your
family and in your circle most of the
time the thing that you should be doing
with your life is very different than
what your parents did or what your
brothers or sisters or cousins or
Community or church people that are
doing yeah and so it takes courage to go
off and do it right if if you're you're
working with women who have a belief
system of well women are supposed to be
this way but then they know that like I
don't want to be that I'm I'm greater
than that I know I'm greater than that
right yeah to have the courage to chase
that dream down I think is important and
that's where I think people like you are
a voice how do you create a business
from all this that you've been doing and
then it becomes something quite quite
quite quite REM
remarkable yeah I think there's lots of
ways to win I think it's more what do
you want to do so I like helping people
so I like I like doing courses but not
just a course but I like I like training
I like I like having somebody in front
of me I like not just here's this course
I never have to see you again I like
seeing the person and coaching them and
guiding them even just before this I was
I was leading my community and it it
actually used to be a course but then I
stopped it as a course and turned it
into a membership because people using a
course but I never got to see them I
didn't get the I didn't get to see the
results of what they were doing and now
I get to meet people every week and see
what they're up to and how I can help
but that's that's not necessarily the
best way to do it it's what do you love
doing so you could sell courses you can
sell Consulting you can sell your
products you can sell your services you
can sell your books you can sell your
speaking you can sell your hosting like
there's so many things you could sell
what is that you actually want to sell
that you love doing but I think it's
really important that when you are
getting started started that you
actually think about how can you turn
this into a business how can you so that
you're not just wasting time like I I
could have dra grown a lot faster in the
early days of my channel too if I
thought about it like a business and
there were less opportunities there less
ways to do it compared to right now but
a lot of people just oh I just want to
be famous okay but how are we gonna make
money doing the thing that you're
creating because if it's just a hobby
most people will probably quit if you
can't figure out a way to make money
most people will probably quit on the
thing and so it's like how do you you
have your purpose and your mission and I
love it yes and inside of that how can
we start to make money as soon as
possible so that you can stay dedicated
to it whoever it is that you look up to
like who's who's done the thing that you
want to do if you love Kanye if you love
Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or Oprah or
whoever it is that you look up to look
at their story look at how they got
started it'll do two things for you one
it'll it'll give you the tactics like
what did this person do to become
successful and two it'll give you the
the motivation because chances are the
people who you look up to started off
with a lot less than what you currently
have right now uh one of the people I
love looking up to is Oprah she you know
was a sexually abused growing up she
didn't grow up with her parents uh her
grandmother raised her she was so poor
that she her grandmother bought bags of
potatoes and used the potatoes to then
sew it into a dress and Oprah went to
school in potato bags it's like just
imagine showing up in school and a
potato bag as a dress you know it's it's
crazy and so it's hard to imagine that
whatever situation you think is so
terrible in your life right now that
Oprah had it you know way worse than
what you're going through and look at
what she was able to do and so people
have done it so getting out of the
excuses in your head of why re what
resources you feel you don't have or
what circumstances life was thrown
against you people with a lot less of
than a lot more and so model their
success and go after it what skills does
someone need to get into this area of
wanting to be an entrepreneur what does
it take I don't think skills are the
problem I think I think you can learn
anything if you have a a commitment and
passion to learn um learn is your one
word you know I think I think learn the
desire and willingness to to go through
crap and learn and get better you could
you can pick up anything and I think I'm
the Testament to that in that I suck at
the start of my channel if you go back
it's embarrassing watching my first
content it's really really bad but I
just kept learning and said I can get
better I'm going to improve I'm going to
keep working I'm going to keep getting
better and and it worked and so more
than any specific skill I think it's the
mindset it's it's the desire to learn
and understand that I can do better if
you take that into any field uh and
match you with some self-awareness I
think you're set like there's so many
different ways to win as an entrepreneur
there's so many different ways yes you
may not win the same way that Gary ve wi
and so the have the self is to know hey
I'm I'm Mara I'm great at talking to
people I'm going to do a talk show and
then you can model success and you can
learn from Oprah and you can learn from
Larry King and you can learn from all
the great talk show hosts and model some
of their Styles and every time you do
that you learn a little bit more to be a
better Mara and keep growing and keep
getting better what is the
entrepreneurial mindset how do they
think wow I think it I think it roots
from a a dissatisfaction with the world
around us uh entrepreneurs are The Crazy
Ones who see a future are upset about
something and then we want to make a
change we I think anybody can pick out
something that they don't like in their
world but the entrepreneurs are the
solution providers they're the ones who
want to find a way to solve it and to
make the world a better place somehow
and I think most of our Global problems
could be solved by entrepreneurs if they
were given the opportunity a feeling
that I have the power to be able to make
a change where I think a lot of people
who might be inside a a corporation or
an organization they see a problem with
how their organ organization is run if
you're you know you work at a library
you see tons of problems with the
library but then you feel oh I can't do
this because I don't have the power it's
not my position it's not my job title
where the entrepreneurial mindset is I'm
going to find a way to make a difference
I'm going to find a way to make a change
if I don't like something at this
Library I'm going to step up and do
something even though it's not my
position uh and so I think adopting that
mindset and just that ability to feel
like I'm empowering myself I don't need
permission from somebody else to say
what I can and cannot do I'm gonna do
something to try to make a positive
impact and uh one for the individuals in
the organization to feel like they can
go and take that leap and then two for
the leaders of those organizations to
empower their team to take risk and do
something different and not say you can
only do what's inside this box humans
are built to serve because if you're not
happy right now it's because you're not
serving and that's that's hardwired into
US serving others helping others hits
the same part of your brain as having
food and having sex so it's it's
literally hardwire into you that you
want to you feel good by serving other
people so if you're not happy right now
you mentioned the word depression if
you're depressed and you're not happy
you're not serving either the world
maybe you have a big mission or big
Vision or the 25 closest people to you
you don't have to have some giant
Mission but you have to feel like you're
serving the people who are closest to
you either one if you're not happy it's
because you're not serving and so the
good news is you can always figure out a
way to serve exactly
and you can serve on a on a you know
really deep level which is what the book
gets into of how to figure out how to
how to serve exactly but even just doing
an act of kindness even just doing one
nice thing for somebody else will will
make you feel better ultimately what I
want people to do is if you woke up and
you felt like today
mattered like you woke up this morning
and you felt like today mattered you're
going to make something today that
matters you're going to you're going to
create something today whether that's a
song or a video or artwork like you're
creating when you're creating something
that has the potential to impact
somebody else's life if you did that
every day you're you're on a path to
happiness believing in ourselves is
being true to ourselves we're not
changing who we are to serve others
we're serving others as we are right and
that's critical the authenticity the
genuiness how how did you segue that to
Sala dancing so I never learned to dance
growing up I always felt kind of awkward
at a club or whatever dancing and uh in
University I decided okay I'm going to I
want to learn how to dance and so there
was a there was a ballroom class that I
took with my then girlfriend not Nina um
and we signed up and took the class and
she never really liked it uh we went
couple lessons maybe a semester and then
she didn't want to do it anymore and it
was a kind of class where you you have
to go with a partner and so I didn't
have a partner and I didn't want to ask
another girl
to be my partner when I'm in a Rel it
didn't feel right you can get in a lot
of trouble doing that Evan Ju Just
saying yeah yeah so it's okay so that's
the end of that whatever fine you know
there's other things to do but then when
we end up breaking up one of the things
I said was well I can go dancing again
like why don't I go learn some dancing
and salsa dancing is the easiest dance
to be able to pick up as a solo person
so what I mean by that is when you're
dancing it's the culture to switch
Partners all the time so even if you
come as a married couple it would still
be normal to dance with other guys for
you and other women for me which is part
of the cult now some people stay
together but for the most part the
culture is very interchangeable part of
the energy I would imagine yes and borom
is very specific it's like you got your
One partner salsa is more of a street
dance and I just fell in love with it
now on paper I'm Too Tall I take big
steps
I don't speak Spanish I didn't learn
this growing up uh you know all of the
things that you would could say are
logical reasons why you shouldn't do it
and I think a lot of us live in the
world of well like I can't do that and I
shouldn't do that without ever even
trying and I wasn't even very good at
the beginning either because a lot of
those reasons but I just loved it you
know there's something about like this
is amazing I had to I I signed up for
two different schools to go learn
because I was a slow learner at it but
just to pick it up and and I love
meeting people I love the connection I
love I love I think also learning a new
skill that you thought was too difficult
also is how you build belief in yourself
to say well I couldn't I can't do that
but then you see that you can raises
your belief level to do other things so
that made me a better
entrepreneur because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to see my one-on-one with my friend Mark
drer check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there do you
want to make money next 30 days then you
start a bis Dev show so let's use a
business as an example okay let's say
architectural firm so let's say it's a a
company here in Toronto if you already
have an existing business and you
already know your ideal referral